The eighth common misconception
or the eighth most common misconception
amongst the non-Muslim Islam is why do
Muslims when Islam is against idol
worship why do Muslims they worship the
Cabba the reply to this eighth most
common misconception is misconception is
that no Muslim ever worship the cabba
the cabba is our it's our direction.
Allah says in the Quran in surah bakar
chapter number two verse number 145 that
wherever you are you face in the
direction of the sacred mosque in the
direction of mazjid haram makkah so kaba
is our direction we Muslims believe in
unity suppose if you want to offer salah
some may say let's pray north some may
say let's pray south some may say let's
pray east some may say let's pray west
which direction do you pray. So for
unity, Allah has told all the Muslims in
the world face the cabba. The kibla is a
direction. So cabba is our kibla. For
unity, we face in the direction. No
Muslim worship the cabba. That's only
direction. And Muslims Alusi in 1154 was
the first person who drew the world map.
And Muslims are the first to drew the
world map. And when they drew the world
map, they drew the south pole on top and
north pole down and Cabba was in the
center. Later on the western ctographers
came and they turned the map upside
down. North pole top, south pole. But
yet the cabba was in the center.
Alhamdulillah. So Islam says wherever
you are if you if you are living in the
north of Caba pray towards the south. If
you live in south of Caba you pray
towards the north. If you are in the
east of Caba pray towards the west if
you're on the west of Cabba pray towards
the east. All Muslims for unity we face
the same direction. When we Muslims go
for omrah of Hajj. We do tawa from
around the cabba circumambulation. Why
do we do circumambulation? Because we
know every circle has got one center. We
are testifying to Allah that there's
only one God. If you know the sayings of
the second calip of Islamat Omar may
Allah be pleased with him. It's
mentioned in Sai Bkari it's mentioned in
Sai Bkari volume number two in the book
of Hajj had number 595 that had Omar may
Allah be pleased with him. He said
pointing at the black stone that I know
that this stone can neither harm me can
neither benefit me. Just because my
prophet touched it and kissed it, I'm
touching and kissing it. This statement
of the second calip of Islam mentioned
in Sai Bkhari's authentic hadith is
sufficient to prove that no Muslim
worship the Cabba or the Hajas. It can
neither benefit us can neither cause
harm to us. We only kiss it and touch it
because the prophet kissed and touched
it. And one more evidence
at the time of the prophet
there were Sahabas who stood on the
cabba and gave the ada and the call for
prayer. We know bilal may Allah be
pleased with him the black slave because
his voice good. Prophet wasallam told
him go on top of the cabba and give the
ad and call for prayer. Now which idol
worshipper will any idol worshipper
stand on the idol he or she worships. So
this proves that we Muslims don't
worship the cabba. Cabba is only the
kibla, a direction for us to